alive as chalk-lined phantoms.
Picture this: You’re out driving, visiting
the more rural towns of your home country.
It’s been a long trip, hours at a time or
sometimes full days spent on the open road,
with brief stops taken only for gas and snacks.
Every time you hit the next town, you stop
for the night, maybe book a day or two at
a local hotel to rest.
Then, you’re right back out on the road
again.
It’s been a little while since you left
the last town, and it’s starting to get
late.
The sun is dipping behind the horizon, and
pretty soon it’ll be night again.
You don’t think it’s a good idea to keep
driving all through the night until tomorrow,
you need to sleep.
The one problem is, you don’t know the highway
you’re on all that well, and the people
at the last town didn’t mention there being
anywhere else to stay for at least a few more
miles.
But then you turn on the radio, accidentally
tuning in to some kind of locally produced
tourism ad.
Through the airwaves and the ever-growing
evening darkness, you hear:
“Welcome to Chalkland, a nice rural town
with a population who just can’t bear to
leave.
Located just off the freeway, you’ll find
our town is filled with all sorts of colorful
folks, who love nothing more than to greet
new faces.
From the moment you arrive, you’ll see firsthand
the Chalkland locals’ love for art and expression,
and we even encourage our younger residents
to get in on the fun and let their creative
flair show!
Chalkland, once you’re here, you just won’t
be able to leave.”
Chalkland?
You’ve never heard of the place; it wasn’t
on any maps when you planned your route, and
it doesn’t even show up on your car’s
GPS.
And what’s more, the people at the last
town you visited never said anything about
it, they said the nearest neighboring city
was much, much further away.
Did they lie?
Why wouldn’t they tell you that this other
town was closer?
You spot a road sign up ahead, pointing towards
the turning for Chalkland, and decide to try
your chances.
A good night’s rest and you’ll be back
on the road… or so you think.
In any small town, there are bound to be secrets.
Local legends, ghost stories, even grudges
between families that have lived there for
generations.
No matter how friendly and unassuming a place
might seem on the surface, there’s always
bound to be something that people just don’t
talk about.
The township of Chalkland, otherwise known
as SCP-277, is no exception, hiding a fair
few secrets of its own.
Although the locals don’t know it, they
are living their seemingly ordinary lives
under constant surveillance.
Operatives of the SCP Foundation have been
integrated among the townsfolk, embedded within
the civilian population to monitor some of
the strange happenings going on in this otherwise
normal town.
So, why not take a walk with us through main
street, down the avenues of Chalkland, as
we draw your attention to some of the mysteries
of SCP-277.
The first thing you’ll probably notice as
you stroll around town are all the chalk drawings.
They’re everywhere, on the sidewalks and
the outer walls of buildings, scribbled on
trash cans and houses.
Practically every playground in town has been
turned into an urban art installation for
these colorful children’s drawings.
Not all that weird at first glance, right?
Perhaps it’s a good thing that the town
encourages its kids to express themselves
by having them draw all over the town with
chalk.
But these images coating the town, on every
street corner and alleyway, they weren’t
drawn with chalk.
These apparitions, found throughout the area
of SCP-277, might look like harmless art.
But not one of them was created in the way
you might expect.
Little Timmy didn’t spend a few minutes
on his hands and knees, dragging a lump of
chalk over the concrete.
Oh no, the drawings found around Chalkland
seem to be projected directly from the minds
of the town’s children.
All their thoughts, their wild and unfiltered
imaginations, have somehow been plastered
all over every surface you can find.
The Foundation calls these images instances
of SCP-277-1, with almost all of them appearing
as figures ‘drawn’ in white outlines.
Creepy, isn’t it?
Like part of a crime scene.
Luckily, some of these projections take the
form of beanstalks, spaceships, anything from
the imagination of the child manifesting them.
An instance of SCP-277-1 doesn’t possess
any physical form or any substantial three-dimensional
body, and the size, shape, style, and complexity
of each ‘drawing’ varies, all depending
on the child that creates them.
Additionally, it’s only children that have
the capability to produce these images, anyone
over the age of pubescence is completely unable
to do so.
As for how exactly the children of Chalkland
create SCP-277-1 instances?
Well, most of the time they aren’t even
aware that they’re projecting their thoughts
into the form of these anomalous drawings.
It’s an entirely unconscious and involuntary
process.
It’s hard for the SCP Foundation to put
an exact number on the number of children
in Chalkland, given the sheer size of the
town and its population.
So, predicting the exact number of active
instances of SCP-277-1s at any one time is
pretty tricky, if not downright unfeasible.
The Foundation agents embedded among the townsfolk
have been able to confirm that these drawings
or projections are capable of interacting
with fellow SCP-277-1 instances, while physical
objects can pass through them without causing
or sustaining any form of damage.
It is due to this factor that the children
living in SCP-277 can often be seen playing
with their chalk projections, and the existence
of these living drawings is viewed as a totally
normal and everyday occurrence by the adult
residents of Chalkland.
In fact, you ask anyone who grew up living
in SCP-277, any lifelong local born and raised
in Chalkland, and they will tell you that
the living chalk projections of the town’s
children have existed as long as the town
itself has.
According to the claims of the older residents,
SCP-277-1 instances have been appearing in
Chalkland for years and years, dating all
the way back to when SCP-277 was first colonized,
and the earliest settlers arrived in the town.
However, the Foundation isn’t so sure that
these claims are one hundred percent accurate.
For one, they can’t even find a single record
of SCP-277 existing before the 2000s.
Even those living in neighboring towns refuse
to believe that Chalkland is a real place
that exists.
Adding to the mystery surrounding the town
of SCP-277 is the fact that all of its inhabitants
also don’t seem to exist, or at least have
no official record of their existence anywhere
else.
According to tests conducted by the Foundation,
the dental, DNA, and fingerprint data of everyone
living in SCP-277 don’t match any recorded
persons on national population databases.
And on top of that?
None of the Chalkland residents have any memories
of living anywhere else other than the mysterious
town, or ever having traveled anywhere outside
it either.
No vacations, road trips, not even as much
as a visit to relatives in the next town over.
Naturally, before they implanted covert agents
among the locals, the SCP Foundation’s initial
attempt to contain SCP-277 was to evacuate
the civilian population.
The plan was to remove the people from the
vicinity of the town, relocate them, and then
assess the local area’s anomalous properties.
What was it about that specific town that
caused the chalk projections to manifest?
Why were none of the residents’ details
anywhere on the national databases?
And how could a single one of them never have
once left the confines of Chalkland?
Evacuate and assess, that was the goal.
But naturally, things weren’t as simple
in practice.
Multiple failed evacuation attempts were made,
with some unforeseen incidents causing the
operations to go awry.
In an attempt to combat this, the SCP Foundation
tried to vary the specific details of its
evacuation strategy each time, but even then,
they couldn’t get the people out of the
town.
What was perhaps far stranger, was that every
time the Foundation attempted a new evacuation,
the civilians living in SCP-277 denied having
any memories of the earlier, failed evacuations.
There was so much disbelief in the occurrence
of these prior evacuation attempts that it
caused the Foundation to question if these
attempts even took place.
The only record of the failed evacuations
existing, were in their own files.
On the odd occasion that Foundation operatives
were able to get one or two residents of SCP-277
far enough away from the town, they learned
it was an exercise in futility.
After spending any longer than a few brief
minutes outside the borders of Chalkland,
a resident would suffer some sort of violent
incident.
The exact nature of what would happen to them
has been redacted, however, we know for a
fact they weren’t killed just by leaving
the town.
Shortly after, these evacuated civilians would
be found back within SCP-277, with no memory
of ever having left the town.
But what was causing all of these attempted
evacuations to fail?
What exactly was preventing the townsfolk
from leaving?
Well, the answers to these questions may be
found in a unique instance of SCP-277-1, which
are far more actively hostile versions of
the chalk drawings that were collectively
given the designation SCP-277-1-R.
These instances first came about some time
before the Foundation started attempting to
evacuate Chalkland.
One of their agents, undercover within the
town and monitoring anomalous activity, spotted
a seemingly standard SCP-277-1 projection,
in the shape of a rabbit.
It wasn’t a drawing that had been noticed
previously, so wasn’t present in any earlier
reports coming out of SCP-277.
But yet, there it was, at the local library.
None of the town’s children admitted to
being responsible for casting this new projection.
Unusual, but not uncommon - after all, they
are kids.
Think about it, we’re sure that as a kid
you might have done something that you didn’t
fess up to when a grown-up asked you.
Granted, you probably never cast a psychic
projection onto a library though.
The Foundation agents within SCP-277 knew
that the instances of the chalk drawings could
often be good indicators of the psychological
state of the child that manifested them, so
they aimed to keep an eye out for any further
SCP-227-1-R rabbits with a matching drawing
style.
Turns out, the agents found plenty more of
these rabbits.
Before long, sightings of SCP-227-1-R instances
had tripled in frequency since that first
one appeared at the library.
But what was it that made these projections
different from the regular SCP-277-1 chalk
drawings?
Well, Agent Davis of the SCP Foundation witnessed
a cluster of these rabbit projections across
the street from a diner.
They were silently watching people or cars
that passed by at a nearby intersection; the
rabbits didn’t play like the other sketches.
Suddenly, the agent heard a scream from a
little girl.
She had been playing with her own chalk drawing
that took the shape of a pony with wings.
Agent Davis turned around to see one of the
rabbits attacking the little girl’s sketch,
practically consuming the drawing thanks to
instances of SCP-277-1 being able to interact
with each other.
At the same time, the attack seemed to be
causing the girl to suffer some form of seizure.
All around, the rest of the rabbits were doing
the same, seeking out other chalk drawings
and devouring them, tearing them apart and
causing the children that had created their
own SCP-277-1s to suffer the same seizure.
Ultimately, any child who had their projection
attacked by a rabbit collapsed soon after,
and slipped into a coma, with attempts to
awaken them proving unsuccessful.
Three months later, all of the rabbit drawings
seemed to have vanished, with no clue if they
had come from a child, or were created from
the town of SCP-277 itself.
The local civilians gave mixed responses when
asked, some claiming to have no memory of
the event that put multiple children into
comas.
Meanwhile, other townsfolk simply stated that
this sort of thing happens in Chalkland every
few years.
SCP Foundation staff noticed that the residents
of SCP-277 seemed to smile too wide when they
explained this, as if their town was a fairytale,
and the massacre was just a part of a happy
ending.
Still, if you are thinking of stopping at
Chalkland, maybe it’s safer to just keep
driving.
Now go check out “You'll NEVER Make It To
SCP-084 - Static Tower” and “The Horror
of Body Stealing Rain - SCP-3300” for more
places you should definitely avoid on your
next road trip!